[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round nine of the
2022 tata still chess tournament you
guys requested it's anish giri versus
sam shanklin both of them doing well in
the tournament so far shanklin only lost
one game at his first round game against
vidit and then he he drew seven games in
a row and
giri is on a winning streak currently so
uh let's see let's see how this one
plays out so anish with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 he goes for the
retti opening and we have d5 uh
controlling the center as one usually
does when white uh uh doesn't grab the
center with the pawns so g3 anish goes
for the king's indian attack and now g6
black will also think of his bishop
bishop g2 bishop g7 and now anish
castles we have e5 black grabs the full
center
in the olden days this was considered a
hyper modern approach to chess where
white doesn't control the center with
the pawns but rather with the pieces and
then later on he can undermine those
pawns
but nowadays it's a very very standard
stuff so here we have d3 and now knight
the c6
interestingly if you uh grab even more
center with c5 then white can use this
to his advantage for example with
something like c4 and then after d4 even
b4 is an idea for example characters a3
and you are already playing white's game
where
uh well you've stopped developing and
you're grabbing material and this is not
how you play a chess in in in modern
times so after d3 knight to c6 this is a
very standard move and now e4 anisha
offers a trade of pawns in the center
and offers a queen trade so sam could
decline this with some like knight g37
then the game continues with c3 and so
on but he accepts it we have d captures
and e4 d captures and queen captures on
d1 we have rook captures bishop to g4
and here sam is very comfortable saying
that okay you uh pretty much given up on
your advantage this is now equal uh what
what are you even doing here so on each
place c3 a very useful move if the
position opens up the bishop will not be
doing all that much plus you control the
knight on c6 uh so definitely a move to
be played we have knight to f6 putting
pressure on the pawn here and knight
beat the d2 defending this pawn we have
queen side castles uh introducing the
rook to the open d file and now white
has to
spend the move uh moving the rook away
from the open file which is not
something you want to do usually you
want to move rooks towards the open file
but here it's needed as well
the knight has to move and your e4 pawn
will be unprotected so here uh there are
some games where this position was
reached night the e8 is a known move but
here sam plays bishop to h6 and it is
now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
so uh there aren't any threats here
although it looks like you know a lot of
pieces are attacked and uh maybe even
hanging they're really not so there's no
way for black to actually exploit this
unless white does something really silly
so knight to c4 now we can move the
knight as the four pawn is protected and
we've opened up an attack towards the
bishop so it's a an offer to trade
bishops which same accepts with bishop
captures rook a to c1 captures and now
as your e5 pawn is attacked twice sam
captures one of the attackers so bishop
captures an f3 bishop captures and now
knights to e8 shifting the knight over
to d6 to trade off even more material
and later on maybe rook to f8 f5 can be
played and black is then
just fine so rook c to d1 now you bring
the rook back to the open file and
knight to d6 offering a trade of knights
but also you are allowing uh white to
trade off the knights uh this way and
then uh black will be left with uh with
a backwards d6 pawn so anish goes for
this bishop to g for check first uh it's
not a check to just give check you you
do it to control the f file and of
course uh f5 cannot be played because we
first eliminate one of the attackers
with check and then of course we win the
free pawn so king has to move we have
king b8 and now knight captures on d6
rook captures and e6 you could also
consider c characters on d6 to maybe uh
keep the rooks on the board but sam
decides to trade rooks rook captures
pawn captures and now uh you have this
position where um
the d6 pawn is a backwards pawn and
usually in an end game one weakness is
not enough to win you need two or three
weaknesses uh of of any kind to you know
uh
expand your advantage throughout the
board and now it seems like uh d6 spawn
is the pawn you really want to go after
and many many people would just play
rook to d1 here go after the pawn then
rook rook row comes to d8 king comes to
c7 and everything is fine for black but
anish realizes that the actual
target is not the d6 pawn but the f7
pawn and he plays rook to e3 a very nice
rook lift preparing rook to f3 so here i
if you go rook to f8 to just rook to f3
and again black does not have f5 so
instead after rook to e3 we have king to
c7 uh bringing the king
into the game as this is what you have
to do in an end game and now rook to f3
going after the df7 pawn so knights the
d8 defending and now h4 so now okay we
have two weaknesses this is this one is
a little bit weak although it's on a
dark square so we have a light square
bishop it's kind of hard to exploit this
but it's something it can never be
advanced to d5 and the f7 pawn is always
a target so here uh the the thing is if
you play rogue fade then we play rook to
f6 and again black is uh struggling to
find the move b6 we're going to play b4
and if if you move the knight somewhere
weird even bishop to e6 is an idea so
it's hard for black to play this but
maybe this passive approach is the best
for for black here but sam doesn't uh
think that a passive is the way to go
here and he starts with a pawn sacrifice
he plays d5 and okay he will uh gain
some space uh white will lose control of
the f5 square he will be able to push f5
so he will he he gives up this weaker
pawn to remove this weakness and create
a very powerful pawn chain so here anish
accepts it with e captures on d5 and now
f5 so okay now you have the the very
nice pawn chain but will you be able to
win your pawn back so here bishop back
to h3 for the moment the bishop is out
of the game but you can always play
bishop g2 bishop to f1 and reintroduce
the bishop back into the game so king d6
are gaining a lot of activity with the
king and now c4 defending the pawn here
and now the thing is if for example king
to c5 then we play bishop f1 and the
pawn is nicely defended if e4 then we
play rook to b3 and everything is
perfectly fine for white but maybe again
this isn't so bad for black here uh we
have b6 uh and now anish has a way of
seizing the day uh but it's not easy as
you can see the the position is pretty
crazy he's up upon but there is one move
that really allows him to fight for
advantage so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
nice breakthrough and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
not pawn to b4 i know you guys were
interested in that it's actually g4 so
like b4 but on the other side of the
board and now you're just threatening to
win a pawn here and you're saying okay
if you capture here i'm going to capture
back and now i have the
semi-open f file for my rook uh and i
have all the activity in the world where
you're really struggling for moves if
your knight ever moves we have the d6
square for our bishop we have the f7
square for our rook and not a lot of
moves for black here for example if
rookie 8 preparing to advance the the e
pawn we can just play king g2 let's say
e4 rook f4 and now after king e5 we can
play king to g3 and again not all that
much
for black here
so instead after g4 sam decides to try
another uh crazy idea he plays knight to
f7 and now g captures an f5 uh we have
g5 and now rook back to a3 going after
the a7 pawn and now the problem is if
you play a5 we're just going to capture
on g5 knight captures bishop to g2 and
the white is just much better here
you're up two pawns true it's a it's a
double f pawn but still a pawn is a pawn
so instead after rook day three stem
continues with his uh over extended plan
g captures an h4 rook captures an a7 and
now knight to g5 putting pressure on the
bishop here so king g2 defending and now
rook the c8 going after the c for pawn
but anish just defends it and creates uh
a beautiful pawn chain of his own so b5
trying to mess up the pawn chain but
just rook to a6 check and now uh if you
go king c5 which seems like something
you want to do you want to get the king
deep into the position as possible then
f6 starts marching and we open up and
attack towards the rook here rook to f8
defending and now rook c6 check king b4
or d4 we're going to play d6 and you
just can't stop both of the pawns if
rook captures on f6 d7 rook
f8 rook to c8 and the pawn is queening
that's just it so instead after rook a6
czech king the d7 was played but this
isn't much better uh we have f6 with
check we move the pawn with tempo so
knight captures on if on h3 if you don't
want to give up the exchange a knight
captures king captures and now b
captures on c4 but here anis just played
rook to c6 and he was in this position
on move 34 that uh sam shanklin resigned
the game and uh well uh seemingly a
spotless victory for anish giri in this
round nine of the tata still chess
tournament
uh so here you resign because if you
capture the rook then we play d captures
on c6 and that's it uh you guys know
that when the pawns are uh two squares
apart the king cannot stop both of them
if you capture this one then this pawn
advances and so on and if you don't uh
trade rooks uh then what what can you
even play with player rugby go after the
pawn then we just play b captures on c4
and we are up uh two pawns and well we
have four past pawns this is of course
unstoppable so after rook to c6 sam
resigned and another beautiful victory
for anisha uh
in this uh in this great tournament uh
interestingly sam was not in time
trouble at all he actually had more time
than anisha throughout the game so
it's uh basically uh basically what this
game is about is that uh shankland just
refused to play a very very passive
position uh it's not that he would
survive a passive position it's just
maybe maybe
there were better chances of surviving
than this uh
active pawn play uh but that's never an
easy thing to do
you really have to you know uh suffer a
lot if you go for for positions like
this and here it didn't work out anish
picks up a point and here are the
standings after uh nine rounds uh so
magnus leading the tournament after that
amazing game against palmetto that we've
checked out yesterday with six and a
half points anish installed second with
six out of nine then with five and a
half month yard of invaded uh with five
uh karaki and karwana and rapport with
four and a half is panko and fun forest
with four young shisht of duda with
three and a half daniel dubom and sam
shanklin with two and a half pragnanda
and uh on two points neil's granddale
use
so those are the standings uh hope you
enjoyed that really a nice game uh very
happy i covered it uh and yeah uh thanks
for watching uh i would like to thank
david kimura thomas earl trevor furtado
souza uh going wok khan and william rose
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day